[Musik]
das war der Rest und meiner heißen
Zitrone meine Damen und Herren und damit
darf ich euch recht herzlich willkommen
heißen hier heute zu einer neuen Episode
Skyblock mit Luca ich habe tatsächlich
[Musik]
wann ist das gewachsen
bei mir wurde das hier in der letzten
Folge in die Kommentare geschrieben von
wegen Leuchten können nur wachsen wenn
man da eben
moin Meister wir haben neuen Baum ey die
Folge geht nicht meine Minute und das
Glück ist schon zurück bei Skyblock mit
Luca wir dürfen aber auch gar nicht
lange Zeit verlieren schreibt mir gerne
unten in die Kommentare was da vorne mit
diesen leuchtbären los ist warum die
plötzlich gewachsen sind was soll ich da
jetzt machen kann ich die essen kann ich
die abbauen was soll ich drücken ich
habe keine Ahnung in die Kommentare und
ich brauche auch mal eben kurz den Baum
direkt ab denn wir benötigen ja ganz
ganz dringend noch immer weitere
Setzlinge und ganz ganz viel Holz denn
unsere Insel soll ja bald umgebaut
werden mir wird das ja auch unten in die
Kommentare geschrieben und wegen Luca
bau doch so kleine runde Kreise hier hin
und so ich habe doch schon meine eigenen
Vorstellungen also danke für eure Ideen
und ähm die ganzen Hinweise wie ich das
ganze cool darstellen könnte allerdings
habe ich schon eine Idee wie ich das
ganze mache dafür brauche ich allerdings
eine Menge Holz und auch noch Erde und
Fichten und Fichten sind da ganz hinten
deswegen ist das heute wirklich erstmal
Prio dass ich auf diese Insel komme und
vielleicht schaffe ich es auch noch zu
dieser Insel da hinten zu kommen weil da
ist eine Birke und eine Birke brauchen
wir eigentlich auch aber ich warte
manchmal ganz kurz ab ob da vorne noch
ein bisschen ach guck mal direkt ein
Apfel perfekt dann kann ich mir mein
Leben auch noch mal wieder neu auffüllen
neuer Baum ey das Glück ist zurück ich
sag's wie es ist man muss einfach
gechillt an die Sachen rangehen hier ein
schöner Tee oder eine heiße Zitrone dass
die verstehe ich immer noch nicht ne
gucke ich weg nee
guck mal jetzt ist da ich weiß nicht was
das für Grafikfehler sind aber naja eine
heiße Zitrone habe ich mir hier gemacht
einfach entspannt an die Sache rangehen
wir dürfen gar nicht so gestresst
rangehen dann klappt das auch deutlich
besser ey fragt euch wahrscheinlich
warum ich meine heiße Zitrone aus dem
Strohhalm trinken muss ich war
tatsächlich gestern hier bei diesem
komischen bescheuerten deutschen
Übergangs Wetter hier wieder im Herbst 5
Grad regen brauchen niemand ähm weil ich
joggen und habe mir danach was indisches
zu Essen gemacht und das brannte dann
voll in meinen Lippen weil die vom
Joggen noch aufgerissen waren deswegen
habe ich mir die auch habt ihr
wahrscheinlich meine insta Story gesehen
äh doll eingekriegt die Eiskönig viele
von euch geschrieben was wahrscheinlich
auch auf Instagram gesehen hat ist dass
dieser Hoodie oder das Wetter ist es ja
mit diesem print hinten ne wunderschön
tatsächlich der kommt tatsächlich
Donnerstag am 1.12 um 18 Uhr raus in den
Läden
also schaut gerne mal Donnerstag also
wenn ihr das Video hier seht wenn es
online geht dann übermorgen am 1.12 um
18 Uhr im luca-shop.de vorbei was ich
allerdings auch mal eben ganz kurz
machen wollte guck mal der nächste Baum
ey das ist doch nicht wahr ich wollte
eigentlich solange es noch hell ist aber
vielleicht kriegen wir es auch noch hin
die Sonne äh neigt sich schon im Ende so
ein bisschen entgegen ich wollte
eigentlich so lange es hell ist noch fix
rüber zu der Insel da hinten das alles
da abbauen damit wir das bei Tag noch
alles sehen kann und das da hinten
nichts Spawn kann man noch ein setzting
jetzt haben wir ja aber so viel zu tun
dass wir wirklich das jetzt im Hellen
gar nicht mehr richtig hinkriegen weil
ich muss auch noch warten bis dass der
Job nicht dass das vergesse aber gut was
mir auf jeden Fall ne warte warte eben
schnell rüber ich nehme eben schnell
einmal mit hier werden Wasserquelle
Zacken Wassereimer brauche ich auf jeden
Fall unten eine Fackel bräuchte ich auch
falls es dunkel werden sollte deswegen
werde ich mal eben kurz hier planks
nehmen es ging doch so oder wenn man
zack nicht andersrum so mache ich mir
ganz kurz eine Fackel ich gehe auch mal
ganz kurz eben noch mal auf den
Kommentare wir haben ganz ganz viel zu
tun die letzte Folge wieder ein paar
Tage her mir wurde das hier nämlich
geschrieben
jetzt ist er weg ist jetzt auch egal wir
wurden nämlich geschrieben an den kann
ich stehen lassen dann kann ich
theoretisch noch einen anderen Baum
hinsetzen er wird geschrieben der Mann
grubensätze der kann da vorne gar nicht
wachsen weil der muss irgendwie im
Wasser wachsen oder so und ich brauche
das Holz eh nicht von dem mangrovenkranz
geguckt wir haben immer noch das Ziel
alle 60 challenges bis Silvester
durchzukriegen das wäre immer auf gar
keinen Fall schaffen aber ich werde mir
auch gar keinen Stress mehr machen mit
dem Projekt ähm ja wir brauchen diesen
Mann großen Setzling gar nicht deswegen
ja keine Ahnung jetzt ist er weg ich
glaube aber wir haben ihn noch einen
zweiten oder ja wir haben sogar noch
vier weitere Keimlinge sind das sogar
die muss man wirklich in den Wasser
setzen und dann wächst wachsen ja auch
ganz anders als Bäume und so aber es
egal braucht man nicht ähm ich habe
schon wieder zwei neue Dinge kann ich
hier noch mal kurz hinsetzen und
vielleicht nehme ich noch mal kurz
brennen äh nehme ich noch mal eben kurz
Erde
man kann ja vielleicht hier vorne auf
der Kippe noch irgendwo einsetzen hier
dazwischen oder so damit wir einfach
alles so ein bisschen voll Kleister ich
weiß es sieht noch nicht so schön aus
ich werde auch heute nichts an dieser
Insel hier machen die Priorität hat
heute auf jeden Fall dass ich da hinten
hin komme und da die Sachen hole und
dann werde ich mich in der nächsten
Folge hier so ein bisschen um die Insel
kümmern das heißt die nächste Folge wird
eine Insel Reparatur das kann ich Euch
jetzt schon sagen ich lasse die Erde
auch erstmal ganz kurz hier bevor ich
darüber laufen und lass generell alles
hier was ich irgendwie nicht verlieren
soll sollte die steinhacke auch das war
davon habe ich genug ich habe eine
Fackel auch noch nicht die nehme ich mir
auch eben fix mit hier Holzkohle raus
zack einen Stick das da rein das da rein
wann Fackel habe ich eine in die Hand
zack die anderen da rein BAM und das war
gerade richtig schnell ne esportlich
runter ne
immer weiter
Memo guck mal wir laufen jetzt
allerdings erstmal rüber da hinten zu
Fichten bzw laufen tun wir gar nicht wir
gehen weil nicht dass ich hier noch mehr
verbrauche guck mal wie schnell das
jetzt plötzlich dunkel wurde in den
letzten 5 Sekunden nee guckt euch das
mal an hier rechts rüber da geht die
Sonne unter der geht der Mond auf und da
hinten ist unsere Insel sind interessant
sehen wir die Monster von hier sehen wir
nicht äh da wurde mir übrigens auch
unten in die Kommentare geschrieben
bezüglich der Monster das hier dass ich
einfach mal eine Nacht lang abwarten
soll gar nicht darüber gehen gar nicht
da irgendwie Stress provozieren sondern
einfach die Monster Monster sein lassen
die machen ihr Ding die kommen ja eh
nicht rüber weil wir da eine Lücke haben
und dann wollte ich ein Wassereimer
dabei ne wenn ich jetzt runterfallen ist
vorbei das Projekt ich komme nicht an
Eisen naja dann fahren wir besser aber
nicht runter auf jeden Fall ähm einfach
die Monster Monster sein lassen in die
Kommentare geschrieben und dann am
nächsten Tag wenn Sonne ist und die
Monster verbrennen dann einfach
rübergehen und den deren Blut holen und
dass ich darüber vielleicht Knochen
Kriege da wurde mir auch geschrieben
Luca Knochenmehl bitte nicht verballern
für Weizen für Gras sondern für Weizen
also nicht das Knochenmehl auf die Erde
rechtsklicken da kriegt man nicht so
viele Samen raus wie wenn ich das
einfach für mein Weizen verwendet plus
ich bekomme dadurch auch noch
Weizen mit Emily oh mein Gott oh mein
Gott
die süßbären attackieren mich hier hey
ich kack doch wieder in meinen Arsch ich
dachte gerade das hier vorne
irgendwelche Monster sind die mich jetzt
hier angreifen oder so aber es waren
tatsächlich die süßbären ich werde mal
eben kurz hier alles unterhöhlen um dann
an ich bin noch nicht ganz unten
verdammt dann werde ich mal eben kurz so
machen ich sitz hier im Wasser einmal
hin gehe runter jetzt müssen wir ganz
vorsichtig sein
[Musik]
bei der Profi einfach einfach der Profi
einfach der Profi haben wir geschafft
okay nehmen wir den Wassereimer direkt
wieder mit zack
und können auch das hier vorne direkt
abbauen das brauchen wir nämlich nicht
mehr dann unterhöhen wir das alles jetzt
mal hier und bauen ah nicht die Fackel
dahin setzen ich bin ein bisschen nervös
guck mal ich stehe hier schon wieder auf
der Kante ne so Fackel immer andere Hand
nehmen damit ihr was seht so ähm ja also
mir wurde auf jeden Fall geschrieben
dass ich die Monster der Monster sein
lassen und dann am nächsten Tag den Blut
abholen soll das ist Sache Nummer eins
sich ganz kurz sagen wollte Sache Nummer
zwei während ich das hier ganz kurz
Abbau ist
dass das hier ja süß werden sind die
mich gerade attackiert haben da wurde
nämlich das hier geschrieben und zwar
Luca bitte die süßspeere nicht wenn du
sie hast direkt essen weil ich dann
verfressende Stück Scheiße bin sondern
bitte die süßbären süßbären sein lassen
und damit eine Farm bauen denn die kann
man tatsächlich gut benutzen um damit
irgendwann auch sich das Essen
aufzufüllen ich bau mich mal ganz kurz
noch mal eben hoch und er wollte erstmal
perfekt und dann bauen wir jetzt auch
mal eben kurz den Baum hier ab so so
Fichtenholz eigentlich lieb ist so toll
wir brauchen wirklich so viele
das war's
mehr Fichtenholz war das nicht
Schnee haben wir auch
ich weiß nicht ob wir irgendwelche
challenges ist Schnee benötigen aber
sonst wird er ja wohl nicht liegen naja
gut okay können wir jetzt nicht mehr
mitmachen wir können einfach nur hoffen
dass jetzt irgendwie Fichten setzt wegen
droppt und dass er dann nicht
runterfällt oder so ein bisschen Schiss
ich will jetzt die Plattform ja noch
größer machen dass ich noch mehr von den
Teilen ja ach guck mal perfekt damals
auch direkt sehr gut kann man Fichten
sehr sehr geil okay dann haben wir das
auf jeden Fall schon erledigt den Kürbis
nämlich mit und wir nehmen natürlich
selbstverständlich die komplette Erde
mit die wir hier noch haben weil die
benötigen wir auch für unsere Insel und
dann werde ich äh werde ich dann jetzt
direkt noch rüber zu einer anderen Insel
gehen oder werde ich erstmal wieder
zurückgehen ich glaube
ich glaube ich werde direkt rüber gehen
ja ich mache euch direkt jetzt eine
timeless weil es ist eh gerade dunkel da
könnt ihr gerade nicht so viel sehen ich
mache euch jetzt direkt eine timeless
wie ich mich so weit es geht rüber baue
zunächst eine Insel
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
ich dachte gerade ich sehe nicht richtig
da ist hier ist den Mini Zombie gespawnt
wahrscheinlich weil die Plattform hier
oh die ist oh nein oh nein oh nein oh
nein
ich Idiot hätte das auf den hätte hier
bleiben müssen ich hätte jetzt nicht auf
der Höhe das heißt hier kann auch was
bauen
hey ich schwöre euch ich bin so ein
Dulli
ich bin noch nicht bis ganz hinten
gekommen übrigens ne mir fehlen noch so
ein Stacks würde ich sagen 64 Stück
fehlen mir noch aber sehe ich dass die
Sonne aufgeht
ja
es wird langsam wieder hell glaube ich
gleich naja
euch auf jeden Fall noch mal eine ganz
kurze timelapse wie ich Cobblestone
abbaue und dann es schaffe zu Insel zu
gehen hoffe ich mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch schon wieder anderthalb Stacks
Bruchstein meine lieben Freunde ich
werde mir allerdings mal eben erst mal
kurz noch mal eine neue Spitzhacke
machen bevor ich wieder den Fehler
begehre und dann das ganze Bruchstein
direkt verbreitet zu den slaps ohne dass
ich mir eine neue Spitzhacke gemacht
habe zack jetzt haben wir wieder drei
sechs die sollten auf jeden Fall reichen
damit wir da hinten noch rüberkommen in
der heutigen Folge was allerdings auch
schon gesehen habe ist das natürlich
wieder die Sonne aufgegangen ist klar
und zwei neue Bäume sind gewachsen
wie geht's dir
ja da hatten wir nicht so die besten
Situationen aber ich freue mich dass du
hier bist also wir schauen mal was er
tatsächlich so hat er will nur
ja nee ich nicht gedacht aber kann ich
mir nicht leisten Emeralds will der hier
haben Alter Smaragde wie soll ich mir
das denn hier irgendwie komm geh machen
Abgang ey wirklich also es ist der hier
und will Emeralds haben von mir und was
gibt er mir im Gegenzug Alter sonst
setzen oder so ein Bums ey mein Weg rum
dass der Baum da gleich nicht wachsen
kann ich nicht schon wieder aus ne so
gefreut er endlich mal hier Leute auf
der Insel weil heute nie wieder ab das
ist ja dieser dieser Händler vielleicht
aus Minecraft Staffel 1 der kommt
irgendwie immer nach ein paar Tagen
Nächten Wochen keine Ahnung was und
bitte dann Sachen an wenn man irgendwie
handeln möchte oder so aber ich habe ja
nichts zum Handeln wenn man schon er
will muss
oder so eine kranke ey komm nie weg also
ich pflanze tatsächlich direkt mal hier
meine Fichten an
Zack und wer tatsächlich genügend Holz
haben also ich glaube heute kein Problem
mehr sein wir haben genug 6 Dinge können
wir die nimmst uns auch mal um die ähm
um die baumfarben so ein bisschen
kümmern jedoch werde ich tatsächlich
jetzt erstmal das leider nichts
gesponnen weil wir die ganze Zeit da
hinten beschäftigt war mit der Treppe
das heißt die Monster hier haben gar
nicht gecheckt dass wir da sind weil wir
zu weit weg waren glaube ich deswegen
konnte nichts spawnen allerdings werde
ich euch jetzt erstmal noch eine kleine
Teil wir müssen die Kiste erweitern
schon wieder spucken nee
aber das ist ein schönes Gefühl zu sagen
wir müssen die Kiste vergrößern
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren da sind wir
auch schon hier vorne direkt bei der
nächsten Insel angelangt wir haben genau
passend Cobblestone Stufen mit dabei um
hier alles zu unterhöhen das Gute ist ja
auch dass wir uns tatsächlich von der
tieferen Plattform da hinten also wo wir
uns schon unter die Insel gegraben haben
rüber gebaut haben hier denn dadurch
benötigen wir jetzt nicht mehr ein
Wassereimer um hier eine ganze Harakiri
Aktion zu machen um die Insel von unten
ab zu äh ihr sichern mit diesem Blöcken
zack zack oder habe ich jetzt einfach
vergessen glaube ich oder wenn ich den
hier abbauen ja da habe ich einfach
vergessen
ab zack bzw gehen vielleicht erstmal am
Rand kurz hoch um den Baum abzubauen so
dass der dann schon mal so ein bisschen
jetzt habe ich auch keine Dings mit
dabei keine Angst leider ähm aber um
auch schon mal hier so ein bisschen das
alles kaputt machen drauf auf der Insel
das heißt wir kriegen auch hier
vielleicht Samen raus zack zack nee nee
aber hier eine Blume hier hier ein
Samenkorn okay
in die Kommentare geschrieben dass ich
ja schon gesagt das Knochenmehl für für
das Weizen besser verwenden soll anstatt
hier irgendwas aufs Gras zu hauen was
mir da auch noch geschrieben wurde waren
war Luca wenn du irgendwann genügend
Samen hast mach dir doch einen Komposter
kennen wir auch noch von Minecraft mit
Lukas Staffel 1 da kann man einfach alle
Sachen die irgendwie was mit Erde zu tun
haben also Blumen auch oder Samen oder
Zuckerrohr kann ich auch mal das hat mir
sogar in der starterkiste drin damit
habe ich noch gar nichts gemacht ähm
kann ich alles anpflanzt kann ich alles
in den Kompost da reinschmeißen und der
Komposter spuckt mir danach nach einer
gewissen Zeit die dementsprechend wie
viel da drin ist dann Knochen mehr raus
das können wir dann glaube ich auch ein
bisschen eher gebrauchen hier bei
Skyblock mit Luca als dann der 70 Namen
weil wir ihn nicht den Platz haben das
anzubauen wenn ich die Erde um das alles
anzubauen das sollte genug
ausgebreitet jetzt setzen das heißt
alles schnell abbauen und weg hier weil
die Sonne geht schon wieder unter und
wir wissen jetzt noch meine Schaufel
kaputt gegangen wir wissen ja leider
dass
ich das hier irgendwie auf eine falsche
Höhe gebaut habe was das da hinten das
ist die die Sandinsel ganz hinten mit
dem Kaktus war das ich habe das ja
leider auf die falsche Höhe gebaut das
heißt es können jederzeit wieder Monster
spawnen von daher schnell weg ich weiß
nicht ob ein Setzling reicht drei Birken
Setzlinge haben okay ich weiß jetzt
nicht wo die anderen haben aber okay das
sollte auf jeden Fall reichen um noch
mehr Birken zu bekommen dann können wir
den Rest hier einfach droppen lassen ich
nehme das hier mit ich werde jetzt auch
noch nicht mal noch ein vierter haben
wir auch noch das da vorne das jetzt wir
brauchen nicht mehr wir haben vier
Birken setzen das reicht vollkommen ich
werde jetzt auch sprinten
wir müssen durchziehen
ich habe jetzt auch keine Zeit diesen
ganzen Weg hier abzubauen das ergibt
auch keinen Sinn weil wir unten rechts
seht ihr ja gerade unten rechts
eingeblendet im Bild auch noch hin
müssen deswegen lasse ich das jetzt
erstmal hier ich wollte eigentlich alles
schön machen
aber wir müssen jetzt erstmal
durchziehen und hoffen dass uns jetzt
kein Monster hier entgegenkommt sich da
hinten schon was nee da ist nichts
es darf nichts spawnen
ich habe wichtige Items dabei
wir müssen einfach positiv rangehen guck
mal wie ich das Video gestartet habe
hier vorhin einfach mit einer Tasse Tee
und zack ist alles gewachsen und alles
hat irgendwie geklappt und plötzlich er
hat alles super funktioniert
Wahnsinn einfach positiv an die Sachen
rangehen und dafür steht auch dieser
Sweater meine Damen und Herren
nee Spaß beiseite Freunde
rausgebracht und mal kurz einen kleinen
realtalk mal mit rein zu packen weil ich
nicht so die Motivation hatte irgendwie
Sachen zu designen und eher immer auch
so basic ich sitze jetzt nicht mit
irgendwie krassen Markensachen von
meinen Videos sondern meistens mit dem
weißen T-Shirt oder so und das finde ich
halt auch ziemlich cool einfach mit zum
hellblauen Vintage-Look bin ich sehr
sehr nice also wenn ihr den kaufen
möchte dann schaut gerne vorbei Luca
Shop da vorne sind Leute
chillig aber wir werden uns gar nicht
mit den auseinandersetzen denn wir haben
hier genug zu tun auf der Insel wir
haben hier vorne ein Baum der gewachsen
ist der ist tatsächlich schon ich mache
erstmal kurz noch eine Axt oder habe ich
die tatsächlich irgendwo ne ich muss mir
eine neue machen
mich regt das so auf dass sie dann die
ganze Zeit am rumrotzen sind ne also ich
hör das ja hier die ganze Sache von der
Seite
mich regt ein bisschen auf
dass die mir jetzt alles kaputt trampeln
kann ich nicht runterschubsen oder so
oder kriege ich dann irgendwie ne will
ich auch nicht ich will jetzt niemand
töten ich habe nur noch drei
hungerkeulen ähm und es ist Nacht und
die Folge neigt sich auch schon wieder
dem Ende zu weil ich will jetzt nicht
schon wieder eine 30 Minuten Folge
machen ich habe auch Angst vor dem nach
vorne deswegen meine lieben Freunde ich
würde jetzt sagen wir machen das so ich
habe auf jeden Fall genügend Erde ich
habe genügend Holz hier vorne ist alles
angepflanzt es ist auch mittlerweile zu
viel mit den Setzlingen ich fühle mich
wie eine Baumschule mittlerweile ich
würde deswegen die Tanz da vorne schon
wieder rum es ist hier wieder ein Baum
gewachsen also wir machen das wie folgt
ich beende an dieser Stelle jetzt das
Video hier ich beende das auch nicht
hier weil ich habe Angst dass mir den
Baum noch irgendwie rein wächst oder so
sondern ich beende das von hier vorne
hier kann man nichts passieren ich
beende da ist schon wieder guck mal der
werden wir direkt in den Kopf gewachsen
ich beende das Video jetzt an der Stelle
wir sehen uns in drei Tagen wieder in
drei Tagen also wenn ihr das Video heute
seht am Freitag sehen wir uns wieder bei
einer neuen Folge Skyblock mit Luca und
da werden wir diese Insel reparieren wir
werden starten mit einer timelaps bis
wieder Tag ist weil er gerade mitten in
der Nacht ist das heißt die nächste
Folge startet in der timelaps und dann
werden wir die Insel reparieren Rapper
ach komm ich bin k.o ich bin ich mache
mir neuen Tee ich schneide jetzt in das
Video wir sehen uns Freitag wieder
Freitag 18 Uhr neue Folge Skyblock mit
Luca haut rein ciao